Die Reportage zur "Corona-Jugend"
löste extreme viele Kommentare aus.
Das freute uns.
Grösstenteils waren sie positiv.
Viele erkannten sich in den Prota-
gonisten und Protagonistinnen wieder.
Es gab aber
auch einige kritische Stimmen.
Auf diese gehe ich kurz ein.
Angefangen beim Thema Masken:
Ja, das ergibt Sinn.
Wir hielten uns beim Dreh
an die Empfehlungen des Bundes.
Wenn wir 1,5 m Abstand
halten konnten,
wir in einem gut durchlüfteten Zimmer
waren,
legten wir die Maske ab.
Wenn wir aber
in der engen Küche waren
oder in der Einkaufsmeile,
wo viele Menschen waren,
trugen wir die Maske.
Diese Szene am Esstisch
mit den beiden -
sie arbeiten im Spital
und fanden, das sei in Ordnung.
Da zwei Personen,
die im Spital arbeiten, das sagten,
fanden wir,
dass wir darauf vertrauen können.
Dann Thema Massnahmenkritiker:
Ein paar Leute sagten,
wir hätten die kritischen Stimmen
zu wenig zu Wort kommen lassen.
Da muss ich ausholen.
Mir war es wichtig,
etwas Unaufgeregtes zu machen
und nicht einfach boulevardesk
irgendwelche krassen Haltungen,
die schockieren, zu zeigen.
Denn ich finde,
es soll repräsentativ sein.
Die kritischen Stimmen,
die im Beitrag auch vorkommen,
z.B. mit Filippa oder mit Flavio,
der die Medien kritisiert,
Silvan, der sagt: "Hey ..."
Der sonst auch
gesellschaftskritisch ist.
Diese Stimmen kommen vor.
Uns war es wichtiger, dass diese
Stimmen nachvollziehbar bleiben.
Dann ...
... fragte ich diverse Personen an,
die z.T. extrem unterwegs sind,
da ich neugierig war
und es zur Vorbereitung diente.
Da waren wirklich auch Corona-Lügner
darunter.
Keiner von ihnen
wollte mitmachen und hinstehen.
Daran kann ich nichts ändern.
Dann Thema junge Kunstschaffende:
Das ist tatsächlich ein Problem.
In meinem Umfeld
sind viele Kulturschaffende,
die jetzt jobben oder zu
irgendwelchen Bürojobs zurückkehrten.
Bert z.B.
ist nicht einfach Barkeeper,
sondern arbeitet
auch in der Eventbranche.
Er hat einen Social-Media-Job
verloren.
Aber gerade die Kulturbranche ist
durch Corona so speziell betroffen,
dass das ein anderer Fokus
gewesen wäre.
Deshalb kam es auch bei uns
nicht so zur Sprache.
Dann Kritik an den Jungen:
Die Menschen, die wir porträtierten,
eckten z.T. an.
Andere schrieben:
"first world problems" etc.
Ich muss da die Protagonistinnen
und Protagonisten
ein bisschen in Schutz nehmen.
Denn z.B. Filippa erledigte im Sommer
extrem viel Gartenarbeit,
Bert rüstete seine Minibar auf
und dekorierte die Wohnung um,
Silvan begann mit Zeichnen
und Vitaparcours.
Flavio war, als wir drehten, gerade
von einer Velotour zurückgekehrt.
Also, ich glaube,
ihnen allen ist klar, dass das Leben
aus mehr besteht als aus Klubs.
Ich glaube, das geht auch
den anderen Jungen - zum Glück - so.
Am häufigsten kritisiert
wurde Filippa.
Ihre Aussagen
sind auch die kontroversesten.
MrRyyon96 z.B. sagt: "Traurig, die
Einstellung der Physiotherapeutin."
"Gut ausgebildet
und im Gesundheitswesen tätig,
verhält sich aber völlig daneben."
"Sie sieht zwar ein,
dass es nicht richtig ist,
redet sich aber damit raus, dass man
diese Kontakte angeblich brauche."
"Egoismus pur."
Ich kann nicht für Filippa
Stellung nehmen.
Mir war es aber wichtig,
auch so eine Stimme zu zeigen,
denn letztlich ist es eine Realität,
dass viele extrem darunter leiden,
im Moment
weniger soziale Kontakte zu haben.
Und ...
Mir war wichtig, dass diese Reportage
nachvollziehbar ist
und sie die Realität abbildet.
Ein etwas anderer Punkt:
Rahel Blindenbacher
und zwei weitere Personen schrieben:
Dessen bin ich mir absolut bewusst.
Ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass das extrem schwierig ist.
Einige Menschen können aus gesund-
heitlichen Gründen keine tragen.
Sie ernten wahrscheinlich im Moment
extrem viele böse Blicke.
Deshalb an dieser Stelle
ein Appell an alle:
Wenn man jemanden sieht,
der keine Maske trägt,
kann man diese Person erst mal
fragen, wieso sie keine Maske trägt.
Das wäre eine gute Idee.
Dann kommen wir zur Sprache:
Dazu gab es zwei, drei Kommentare.
Okay.
Schau, ich spreche, wie ich spreche.
Auch wenn ich eine SRF-Kamera
vor der Nase habe.
Mir ist es viel wichtiger, ein na-
türliches Gespräch führen zu können,
als irgendwie ...
... mich zu bemühen, wie eine pro-
fessionelle Journalistin auszusehen.
Und ...
Hey, schau, ich bin
im Berner Oberland aufgewachsen -
dort spricht man halt so.
Dann noch etwas Allgemeines:
Hie und da kam die Frage,
weshalb der Fokus auf den Jungen lag,
wo es im Moment
doch für alle schwierig sei.
Diese Reportage entstand,
weil die These im Raum stand,
dass es für die Jungen
extrem schwierig sei.
Sie können nicht ausgehen,
sind am stärksten eingeschränkt.
Wenn du mit 18
und jedes Wochenende unterwegs bist,
ist es jetzt vielleicht krasser,
zu Hause zu bleiben,
als wenn du 40 bist und
eh nicht mehr so häufig rausgehst.
Wir merkten aber
im Verlauf der Reportage auch:
Die Jungen sind noch flexibler,
anpassungsfähiger
und gut virtuell vernetzt.
Eine grosse Rolle spielte auch,
dass die wenigsten mit 25
Kinder ernähren müssen
oder Leute
in die Kurzarbeit schicken mussten.
Viele Junge tragen auch noch
weniger Verantwortung.
Die Konsequenzen dieser Massnahmen
trafen sie nicht so hart.
Klar, es gibt immer Sonderfälle.
Ich kenne auch Personen, die
drei Monate alleine zu Hause waren,
ohne Berührungen, ohne jemanden,
denen das extrem Mühe bereitet,
die das
auch noch nicht überwunden haben.
Aber unter dem Strich handhaben es
die Jungen grösstenteils megagut.
Wenn noch weitere Fragen auftauchen
oder ich in diesem Video
wieder zu viel geflucht habe,
kann man uns das
in den Kommentaren wissen lassen.
Vielen Dank für die Reaktionen.
Und ... Ja, bleibt gesund.